yes thank you I'm just
I lost my total smell and my taste
except the sugar and and the sweet on my
taste and that's starting to go I've
been tested I am off the candy off the
charts this woman test me for that she
never saw that in her life
I had irritable valve but that went away
I haven't possibly got leaky gut Jo how
much you a weigh 171 okay how tall are
you um five three now okay you shrunk
yeah how much have you tried Kabhi an
inch okay all right okay Charmaine what
do we do for Paula she's and I think
we've talked before somebody has asked
for your behalf because I've heard the
story before
she has a history of your bowel syndrome
leaky gut syndrome and she's losing her
sense of the smell and taste and of
course she's shrinking and she's in five
foot three I'd like to see her weigh 120
something like that so she needs lose 50
60 pounds what would you do for this
girl well I would get her on a
gluten-free diet immediately okay and
yeah okay gluten free yep and none of
the bad stuff you know no burnt animal
fat no meat with nitrates or nitrates no
fried foods no food aisles no sugar cut
out the sugar okay now there's two
reasons only you interrupt you here real
quick there's two reasons why people can
lose their sense of smell and taste
both of these are nutritional convenient
racial deficiencies there are certain
nutrients that are acquired or these
processes these chemical processes to
take place and of course there's nerves
involved in this also and so you can
have in the facts you're shrinking
contributor says that you might be
having osteoporosis at a skull and
squeezing the roots of these nerves they
come out for the brain through the skull
okay sharp we got rid of the bad foods
the fried foods processed meats oils and
gluten no wheat brought around oats
because of course there's a gluten
problem
here were the irritable bowel syndrome
and leaky gut syndrome shrinking loss of
sense of smell and taste or overweight
all these things go along with
nutritional deficiencies that can result
from the damage and intestines from
gluten okay and so would you give her as
a supplement program Wow I'm 771 pounds
personally for all those issues I would
give her two healthy brain and heart
packs and you know the vitamin d3 okay
and how much glucose L would give her to
support remote means repair of the discs
between her vertebrae
I'd give her at least 12 a day or more
yeah I'd go with 15 two large bottles
come on to the gluco gel so I can take 5
ik breakfast lunch and dinner vitamin d3
and have her take three of those
capsules today's soup I was a month what
would you do to help her lose had 50
pounds I'd give her something rev Rev
and to rev to it okay very good rev says
dropper bottle put a dropper full under
your tongue Paula leave it absorbs for
oral tissues it won't hurt you if you
swallow it but you're not going to get
maximum benefits so you want to leave it
at door for old tissues takes a minute
or so and within a day or two you'll
begin to lose a half a pound of 2 pounds
a day as long as you stay on your 90 for
Life program as long as you stay on the
19th century nutrients 16 minerals 16
bottom that's already assets you'll be
able to maintain you weight loss and of
course you can take the keto caramel
shake and the keto caramel meal bar for
two meals a day so that one or the other
not both in other words you can have the
meal bar cue a caramel meal bar for
breakfast and dinner or you could have
the keto caramel shake for breakfast and
dinner or get him one shake for
breakfast and a meal bar for lunch or
dinner then have a small meal on a small
salad plate or a coffee cup saucer you
do not want to use the 11 to 12 inch
diameter
normal dinner platter you want to have
it you know make sure one layer no
affair stacking up food on the small
plates like a traffic cone out there and
you'll lose the weight keep it off
and give us a call every two weeks let
us know how you're doing with your sense
of smell
whether you're regaining some of your
Heights and so forth and how some of
your other issues are going